[Music]
here in this list we will showcase the
10 most powerful celestials we will have
the ones that are impressive in their
feats and position in power as well as
unique we have shrugged off the ones
such as madonna nowhere and the
gardeners who are officially dead now in
the main marvel timeline and the younger
ones like starchild and gamil the
manipulator who are still underdeveloped
in terms of powers and maturity so let's
take a look at the top 10 most powerful
of these space guards
number 10 the progenitor it was kind of
hard to fill in the lower spots but we
think that the progenitor would fill
this ranking after being infected by the
heart the progenitor came to earth 4
billion years ago to die a sad and an
agonizing death the celestial's diseased
body fluids seep into the earth and
percolated through its primordial
surface he is on the 10th spot due to
his resilience against the horde and he
still died in the end but hell on for a
while and with his death he changed the
course of earth's destiny
number nine isaan the searcher isan was
the seeker and questor among the cosmic
entities known as the celestials isan
was among the first and the fourth
celestial host that visited earth isan
had been quite active such as fighting
galactus along with three other
celestials he has single-handedly
destroyed an empire of deviants without
breaking a sweat and at a point in time
he wielded the power stone and destroyed
planets with it
number 8 jamiyah the analyzer the
extents of the celestial's power is
unclear and their limits having been
barely seen the celestials are likely to
have an unrevealed physical and psionic
powers jimaya was one whom two powerful
celestials ison and gammon have to
report to therefore he holds a higher
position in their arch he has been
present in the first hose and till the
fourth one and was also involved with
eternity to foil the plan to destroy the
universe by the elders
number seven callous devoid he is a
member and may be the leader of the
final host of the dark celestials a race
of celestials transform and turn feral
by the horde the entrance of the dark
celestials also triggered the emergence
of insects from the horde that had been
dormant deep beneath the earth's surface
the celestial eson managed to stand up
and battle the dark celestials but
callous subdued and decapitated him
demonstrating the dark celestial's might
number six arishim the judge holding the
titular position of the leader of the
celestials arishim the judge or the
prime celestial as stated in the mcu was
a red colored celestial with powers that
can be said to be a bit above the rest
of the average celestials he endeared
the combined assault of odin zeus and
vishnu without suffering any damage
although he has been bested in the past
by other celestials like tiamat and also
the dark celestials
number five skathan the approver this is
a mysterious celestial that has appeared
on rare occasion in the marvel universe
one of his most notable appearances that
demonstrates his superior powers is when
the living tribunal called for his help
when judging the case of the prodigy a
god-like infant the living tribunal
summoned scattering who disapproved of
the scenario and imprisoned prodigy with
a celestial muzzle after the protege
copied the living tribunal's power
number 4 exeter the executioner exeter
appears to be kind of a title a function
or a model among the celestials so if an
exeter died another one would eventually
take its place exeter's purpose was to
destroy the life on worlds which failed
the celestial's test
exeter controls cosmic energy with an
unknown upper limit and is nearly
invulnerable
it is said that the exeter spouse is
superior to galactus the in-betweener
and odin or zeus and can affect reality
on a universal scale
number three tiamat the dreaming
celestial the dreaming celestial
formerly known as tiamat the
communicator was one of the celestial's
tasked with informing the fulcrum of the
celestial's findings during planetary
examinations the dreaming celestial
deemed arishim to be malfunctioning
during one of the celestial's missions
and attempted to take authority by
fighting and eventually subduing him but
he was then attacked by all the other
celestials and overpowered he was also
the only one that galactus is afraid of
and the only one who would join the
fulcrum as a companion in the universe
number two ego the living planet the ego
in the mcu and the main marvel
continuity is way different
the one in the mcu is young and killed
by the guardians of the galaxy whereas
the other one is as old as the universe
itself and was a sworn enemy of the
devourer of worlds and has defeated
galactus in the past but he is still one
of the most powerful celestials as he
has the ability to transform the entire
cosmos into an extension of himself via
the planned expansion
and on the number one spot we have the
one above all this mysterious leader of
the celestials is rarely seen once when
the celestials were decimated when the
abstract entities lord chaos and master
order combined into logos to establish
themselves as the new incarnation of
multiversal law the queen of nevers was
able to safely transport the one above
all into the land of couldn't be and
shouldn't be the queen of nevers
utilized him to initiate a celestial's
revival during the last battle against
the demonic first firmament who had been
pulling the strings behind logos which
means that
the most important of the celestials is
the one above all and maybe the most
powerful of them all
and also no he isn't the one above all
god of marvel he is the one above all
the celestial and so with that we come
to the end of the video do hit that like
button for support and click on that
subscribe button as well to be a part of
the mind care family but most of all
smash that bell icon for regular updates
on new monster videos right here on this
channel till the next one
take care fam